schon die täglichen nachrichten nach
ihren auswirkungen der
hochwasserkatastrophe hier in dieser
region übersteigen unsere
vorstellungskraft werber in die
verzweifelten gesichter der menschen
hier
wer die von erschöpfung gezeichneten
gesichter der einsatzkräfte sieht der
kann mindestens erahnen welches leid die
menschen hier in dieser region ertragen
hier in den betroffenen regionen in
nordrhein westfalen nun natürlich auch
ebenso im nachbarland rheinland-pfalz
wir haben menschen getroffen die
vieles verloren haben viele haben alles
verloren was sie sich ihr leben lang
aufgebaut haben
hab und gut ihr heim ihr dach über dem
kopf
wie sehen botschaften wir sehen
gemeinden die von verwüstung von
zerstörung gezeichnet sind
vieles ist verloren und nicht leicht
wieder herstellbar habe der größte
verlust den haben diejenigen zu tragen
die angehörige verloren haben in den
fluten
wir trauern mit denen die ihre freunde
bekannten familienangehörige verloren
haben ihr schicksal zerreißt uns das
herz
es ist eine
seit der not
und in der not steht unser land zusammen
ich bin sehr froh darüber dass nicht nur
hier aus der region sondern aus ganz
deutschland zeichen der anteilnahme des
mitgefühls der solidarität signalisiert
werden
und ich finde es sehr gut dass die
länder und der bund sehr frühzeitig
signalisiert haben dass denjenigen die
vieles verloren haben die große verluste
erlitten haben dass ihnen hilfe zuteil
werden soll
und diese hilfe die zugesagt ist soll
auch gelten für die gemeinden die in den
nächsten tagen und wochen nicht nur
aufzuräumen haben sondern die vieles
wieder herzustellen haben straßen die
kaputt sind rücken die verloren gegangen
sind und deshalb ist es gut dass solche
unterstützung zugesagt ist
ich freue mich ebenso darüber dass wir
heute viel gelegenheit gehabt haben
mit einsatzkräften zu reden
einsatzkräfte die hier vor ort egal ob
von den feuerwehren von der dlrg vom
roten kreuz vom thw und vielen vielen
anderen organisationen dass viele von
ihnen bis schöpfung grund jenseits davon
gearbeitet haben und wie wir eben gehört
haben bereit sind hier zu bleiben ihren
einsatz fortzusetzen ich danke ebenso
neben den einsatzkräften auch den
manchmal vergessenen mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter der gemeindeverwaltungen
die die einsatzleitung und viel
koordination der mit einsatzkräfte
überhaupt zum einsatz kommen vor ort
geschultert haben das ist nicht nur viel
arbeit das ist vor allen dingen viel
verantwortung weil der bedarf und der
ruf nach hilfe
aus allen teilen der region natürlich
groß und drängend ist man wirklich tief
empfundenen dank den ich glaube ich im
namen aller deutschen hier ausrichten
kann
wir sind heute am vierten tag des
hochwassers in der region
das wasser geht zurück
aber möglicherweise wird erst in den
nächsten tagen sichtbar werden welche
schäden bleiben
möglicherweise wird erst in wochen
geklärt werden können
wie groß die schäden sind die zu
ersetzen sein werden
vielleicht erst zu einer zeit in der das
hochwasser die katastrophe die tragödie
die viele menschen hier erlebt haben
schon gar nicht mehr die titelseiten der
deutschen tageszeitung tal deutschen
tageszeitungen bestimmen
ich sage das weil die menschen hier
darauf vertrauen dass die solidarität
die signalisiert wird auch weiterhin
besteht
auch wenn die headlines der deutschen
tageszeitungen von der
hochwasserkatastrophe nicht mehr
dominiert werden
denn der schaden ist groß die
aufräumarbeiten werden dauern und die
unterstützungsbereitschaft sie muss
anhalten
im großen wie im kleinen und jeder kann
etwas tun sie alle wissen spendenkonten
sind eingerichtet worden und wer will
kann sie über die tageszeitungen
erfahren jeder kann seinen teil dazu
beitragen dass ein wenig von der not der
menschen hier in den betroffenen
regionen gelindert wird
wir dürfen nicht vergessen
vielen menschen hier in den regionen
ist nichts geblieben außer ihrer
hoffnung und diese hoffnung dürfen wir
nicht enttäuschen
vielen dank
fragen
dankeschön
meine damen und herren noch mal die
kamera zwei uns nimmt die einst wäre uns
auch recht gewesen also meine damen und
herren ein bundespräsident äußert sich
aber er beantwortete sehr selten fragen
deswegen haben wir das jetzt hier so
gezeigt deswegen ist auch armin laschet
der besuch mit ihm gemeinsam gemacht hat
tatsächlich nicht gemeinsam mit ihm vor
die presse sondern er gibt jetzt separat
sein steak landrat frank rock wir haben
zunächst die bundespräsidentin zu danken
dass er hier nach erftstadt gekommen ist
eine stadt die ganz besonders von dem
schrecklichen unwetter betroffen war und
wo auch in windeseile spürbar war wie
das leben von einer sekunde auf die
andere nicht mehr gleich war
wir haben uns heute die situation vor
ort angeschaut die lage ist immer noch
dynamisch die einsatzkräfte sind immer
noch unterwegs ich denke derzeit in
einem altenheim wo noch mal eine
besondere situation aufgetreten ist
wir versuchen die erft zu stabilisieren
den fluss der den boden aufgeweicht hat
und viele folgewirkungen noch hat und
alles das findet jetzt zu minute noch
statt
wir haben mit anwohnern geredet die
nicht zurück können in ihren ort blessem
der ort der zur erftstadt gehört und am
gestrigen tag ganz besonders betroffen
war und wir haben gleichzeitig auch die
bundesstraße gesehen wo immer noch nicht
alle fahrzeuge geborgen sind und wir die
situation haben das bisher
glücklicherweise keine todesfälle
passiert sind ganz sicher weiß man es
noch nicht weil noch nicht alle
fahrzeuge und alle keller inspiziert
worden sind und beeindruckend auch für
mich war die begegnung mit den
rettungskräften
das sind einmal die das professionell
machen und jetzt im einsatz sind und das
sind zum anderen die die sich
ehrenamtlich engagieren viele derer die
sie hier sehen bei den johannitern dem
thw bei der deutschen lebens rettungs
gesellschaft dlrg machen das
ehrenamtlich sind freigestellt wurden
von ihren arbeitgebern damit sie diesen
einsatz leisten uns das ist das für mich
beeindruckende dass man sieht wenn eine
solche krise auftritt dann ist das land
in der lage sehr schnell sehr
solidarisch zu handeln
dann sind hunderte bereit alles stehen
und liegen zu lassen und vor ort ihre
arbeit zu leisten und deshalb mein dank
an all diese helferinnen und helfer wir
werden als land in den nächsten tagen
alles tun die mittel zu organisieren die
jetzt nötig sind in der direkthilfe hier
in erftstadt wird menschen die in not
waren sehr unbürokratisch geld
ausgezahlt
man kann sich ja vorstellen wenn eine
ganze wohnung zerstört ist nichts mehr
da ist gibt es auch kein geld mehr keine
ec karte mehr gar nichts mehr
und da unmittelbar zu helfen ist das
aller aller wichtigste jetzt in den
nächsten tagen und dann wird man
natürlich strukturell städten wie
erftstadt und vielen anderen im ganzen
land helfen müssen
das alles wieder aufzubauen und der
wiederaufbau
das ist die große aufgabe wohl land und
bund zusammenarbeiten
ich werde schon in den nächsten tagen
auch noch einmal mit dem
bundesfinanzminister sprechen was bund
und land hier gemeinsam bewegen können
heute noch einmal meinen dank an alle
die hier tätig sind ein großer respekt
für das was hier geleistet wird und auch
wie das organisatorisch zusammenläuft
das können sich viele menschen
wahrscheinlich gar nicht vorstellen
die wissen was hier zusammengeführt
werden muss man gerade kurz beim
krisenstab bei der arbeit alle einheiten
zusammen zu bringen
alle hilfsangebote zu ordnen und dann
dahin zu bringen wo hilfe nötig ist das
ist die aufgabe die jetzt geleistet
werden muss mein dank an alle akteure
hier in erftstadt
ja ich möchte ich diesen dank gerne
anschließen der dank gilt aber auch
unserem bundespräsidenten und auch
unseren ministerpräsidenten dass sie den
weg zu uns in den rhein erft kreis
gesucht haben und auch gefunden haben
wir haben eine situation die wir uns vor
einigen tagen vor einigen wochen nicht
vorstellen konnten
und ich glaube für mich und das
wichtigste ist das thema helfen und
danke sagen die solidarität die wir
spüren bei all den beteiligten vor allem
natürlich mit dem blick auf die
bürgerinnen bürger die hier wirklich
psychisch ihr hab und gut verlieren
auch im grunde genommen der situation
sehen hilflos zu sein dass wir in der
solidarität hier im rhein erft kreis
aber auch im land und bund ist schaffen
solch eine krise gemeinsam zu meistern
trägt uns alle die in verantwortung sind
in der krise und darum kann ich meinen
großen land nur an alle aussprechen die
hier mit kleinigkeit mit großen dingen
helfen und so können wir gemeinsam als
team hier im rheinland aber auch mit den
hilfen aus dem land von
ministerpräsidentin vom kabinett aber
auch genauso vom bund die krise meistern
mein dank an alle die hier gemeinsam an
einem strang ziehen
[Musik]
sehr geehrte damen und herren sehr
geehrte zu hörende der besuch des herrn
bundespräsidenten und des herrn
ministerpräsidenten ist uns eine große
ehre und die zeigt ganz deutlich die
wertschätzung unserer arbeit und die
tiefe verbundenheit zu unseren
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürgern hier in
erftstadt
ich wünsche allen betroffenen wir reden
hier von etwa 6000 menschen bei einer
stadt von rund 50.000 einwohnern von
herzen dass sie viel kraft haben mögen
in den nächsten tagen in den nächsten
wochen und monaten beim wiederaufbau
ihrer wohnungen und beim zur rückkehr
bei der zur rückkehr in ihre ortsteile
ich bin zutiefst betroffen und ich
möchte hier ganz deutlich mein mitgefühl
ausdrücken und ich darf ihnen sagen dass
wir hier mit aller kraft daran arbeiten
rund um die uhr ihnen hier hilfestellung
anzubieten und unbürokratisch
finanzielle hilfen zu geben
unser krisenstab wurde unmittelbar
eingerichtet und ich bin überaus dankbar
dass wir bundesweit unterstützung
erhalten haben es sind sechs
rettungshubschrauber im einsatz 35
rettungsboote aus dem ganzen
bundesgebiet die uns hier vor ort
unterstützen und so wird es jetzt in den
nächsten tagen erforderlich sein die
infrastruktur wieder aufzubauen den
verkehrsinfarkt ist den wir zwischen
unseren beiden großen ortsteilen
lechenich und liblar hatten jetzt wieder
herzustellen und aufzulösen so dass wir
auch die nahversorgung der evakuierten
sicherstellen können wir haben immer
noch in unseren beiden unterkünften
viele hundert menschen untergebracht die
unsere unterstützung benötigen
und ich danke auch ganz ausdrücklich
allen mitbürgerinnen und mitbürgern die
sofort ihre hilfe angeboten haben
unterkünfte bereit gestellt haben und
einfach für uns da sind
mein ganz herzlichen dank dafür das ist
ein großes zeichen der solidarität und
unterstützung in diesen schweren stunden
bitte halten sie die kraft und die
stärke die nächsten
wochen und monate hier durchzuhalten
dankeschön
[Musik]
erst einmal gelernt hat sagen also in so
einer katastrophenlage die auch noch nie
dagewesenes ist von frühen wahnsystem zu
sprechen also wir haben auf der brücke
zu 265 angesprochen da ist ein teil
weggebrochen die autos sind in minuten
voll gefahren geflossen das schafft man
nicht das ist eine außergewöhnliche
situation
wir haben alle die wetterwarnungen
erlebt jeder von uns der hier wohnt im
rhein erft kreis hat gemerkt es kann
regen kommen aber so wirklich spüren
kann es dann erst in dem fall wenn es
dann auch so ist und dann wächst das
wasser schneller als wir gucken können
und ich glaube dass dieses gefühl da ist
hier aber alles dafür tun werden dass
aber die hilflosigkeit ein stück ein
ende hat wir arbeiten 24 stunden daran
aber in der krisensituation zu sagen man
hätte früher melden müssen die haben
situation bürger viel zu früh in ihre
häuser zurückgekehrt sind
also ich glaube
nach der krise kann man analysieren wie
man hätte dinge verändern können
wir sind aber noch in der lage das für
die krise bewältigen sind
das ist auch größer ich habe es ja
gerade eben beschrieben
wir sind da im moment ja noch mitten in
der lage situation wenn ich wissen wie
entwickelt sich die elfter weiter die
wir müssen jetzt sehr schnell auch
experten für statik hierher bringen die
genau das untersuchen wie ist die lage
der häuser wies starte ich sicher sind
die was ist mit den brücken und dann
wird die nächste aufgabe seien der
wiederaufbau und das ist das wo wir als
land und bund alles tun müssen das was
wir erleben ist eine
jahrhundertkatastrophe
es ist auch eine nationale aufgabe und
ich bin deshalb froh dass sowohl der
bund als auch die kolleginnen
ministerpräsidenten in den anderen
bundesländern alle gesagt haben
wir stellen das zusammen und das ist
gleichzeitig in diesen worten liegt auch
die zusage ganz deutschland wird hier
dieser region helfen alleine werden dass
weder die kommunen noch das land stemmen
können
aber wir werden alles tun dass wieder
aufgebaut werden kann was wieder
aufzubauen ist
das ist dann die nächste große aufgabe
genau zu sehen wo sind härtefälle und
wir haben uns vorgenommen dass wir das
oder hochwasser 2002 und dann 2013 noch
einmal zum maßstab nehmen um sowohl
individuell die individuell zu helfen
in härtefällen zu helfen und
gleichzeitig bei der struktur beim
wiederaufbau auch da zu sein nur das
kann man im moment noch nicht für jeden
einzelfall beantworten
es wird aber eine strukturelle hilfe
geben die dänen die in not sind zugute
kommt und das was mich aber die nächsten
tage beschäftigen wird das ist auch im
landeskabinett eine rolle gespielt hat
wir müssen alles tun das nicht
obdachlosigkeit entsteht
man spricht jetzt schon so leicht über
wiederaufbau aber eben als wir auf dem
feld gestanden sind uns zwei menschen
begegnet
sind uns zwei menschen begegnet
eigentlich guter dinge aber sie können
nicht in ihr haus zurück wenn man sich
das für sich einmal persönlich vorstellt
wenn man mir jetzt sagen würde du kannst
jetzt gleich wenn du hier fertig bis
nicht in deren haus zurück dann kannst
du glück haben dass du freunde hast oder
verwandte hass wurde unter kommst aber
der der das nicht hat der braucht jetzt
unmittelbar hilfe und das sind die
aufgaben die die bürgermeisterin der
landrat auch ich selbst nicht mich in
den nächsten tagen widmen will
wie können wir genau denen helfen die
dich wissen wo sie hin sollen und das
vergisst man oft wenn man über die ganz
großen szenarien spricht was das für
jeden einzelnen bedeutet deshalb ist das
meine erste priorität im nächsten tagen
der deutsche nationalgoalie
warum warum legen sie ihn eine frage
eine unterstellung wir müssen den
klimawandel ernst nehmen wir haben ein
klima ausstiegsgesetz also ein
klimagesetz des bundes verabschiedet
hier in dieser region steigen wir
schneller als alle planungen meiner rot
grünen vorgängerregierung zehn jahre
früher aus der kohle aus was gerade für
diese region auch für die arbeitsplätze
eine menge bedeutet aber wir sagen es
ist wichtig weil der klimawandel eine
große herausforderung ist wir haben zum
zweiten ein klima anpassungs gesetz im
land beschlossen das genau mit solchen
situationen umgehen soll
und ich werde mich dafür einsetzen
vielleicht gemeinsam mit anderen ländern
das auch auf der bundesebene
klimaanpassung genauso ernst genommen
wird wie der kampf gegen den klimawandel
und meine aussage war wir brauchen da
mehr tempo und genau daran arbeiten wir
co2 reduzieren damit deutschland seinen
beitrag leisten kann
[Musik]